we have some home movies to show you
let's let's take a look at some home
movies this is at Paramount Studios
where you made films first as an actor
with your partner Dean Martin and then
you decided to direct films and this is
some footage of your stage at Paramount
this was your comedy stage you had your
own stage where you made your films and
and it said Jerry Lewis comedy stage
stage 15 and what I'm taken by this
photograph this is from our Academy
archive it there's a picture of you
there and it says this is not a closed
set I always wanted people to be free to
come to the set to see what we do to
make the final product and it was
important to me because I saw how my
crew was affected by we had bleachers on
this side bleachers on that side this
would hold 240 this would hold 400 and
it was full all the time
never a word destroyed a scene never a
sound gotten away it was incredible and
I it helped me tremendously because I
was getting a little taste of what this
stick was doing and that's an audience
there I uh I just had a look at them to
see if that's working or not so it was
very good for me it was also
tremendously helpful for my crew because
I wasn't the only ham on that set every
member of that crew would stroll over to
the bleachers I i do the lighting here
he's nothing unless I show up get out of
here
and so we were learning all these jobs
but you also were at the studio where
you can learn from other filmmakers
other directors on the lot where you're
not I mean you were there during a time
when Hitchcock or others DeMille were
actively so did you I guess the yellow
Hitchcock you're not gonna get a left
with that and you were right yes but
then he threw Kim Novak out of the
window in vertigo he said I got it
Yeah right that was funny did you ever
sneak out of a set up in the rafters and
just look down I did it all a lot of the
pictures that we saw when we went
through the production stills showed
that you had signs on the set like here
these are motivational signs a this was
for actors and they loved the attention
and it only took me less than five
seconds to do something that was for
them and they recognized that and I
would tell them I'm so happy you're with
me on this film I'm so grateful that you
are the performer you are and I am the
happiest man alive and I had to show
them that happiness because it was part
of how I structured everybody that came
on that set and the structure was
basically simple have fun have a good
time don't walk around like someone in
the upper offices it might have said
something to you that upset you don't
bring it to my set because I don't want
to hear it
but I'll get to him and fix his ass I
guarantee you now there was a picture of
this other technology
we saw it we saw it in use it was called
the not listening stick I know did you
in did you invent this technology it was
a I had 500 of them I was selling him to
the people on the set because the non
listening stick meant one shot to the
behind to any actor or actress that
wasn't listening and actors God bless
their souls they can hear you but
they're preparing what they're gonna say
already and when they didn't listen I
told them for years that was one of the
biggest problems with an actor doing an
exceptional role as an actor actress but
there were times when they went off
somewhere and I look in the eyes they're
not looking at me there's the they're
pointing their eyes at me but they're
looking at abroad over there or a guy
over there or something they wouldn't
listen and I finally gave him one shot
on the behind and they worked very good
after that so it was just a gag but it
worked for me